- YouTube, Facebook, happy Sunday morning.
Happy Father's Day to
all the dads out there.
Jordan, you're right
there, good to see you.
We can leave now Jordan
but you can walk with me.
I just want to do a raw to the face
video on this Sunday morning.
We've been doing a lot of Keynotes,
a lot of DailyVees for
YouTube and Facebook
but just wanted to do a little rant
from the kind of, the
hip, right from the dome.
Just want to thank you so much,
your comments are my oxygen.
I say it over and over,
you'd be blown away
by how much I breathe with feedback.
To me getting that feedback from you guys
is just amazing and I'm just
so grateful and thankful
and just wanted to make
a raw kind of quick video
just thanking you so, so,
so much for all of that.
The community is the game,
the process is the game,
and I've hit that kind
of quiet crescendo moment
where I'm so in tune
with putting out content,
putting it out there,
letting you guys consume it,
reading your feedback in this viral loop
and it just feels like I'm in that zone
And every day I wish
for you guys out there
in the world to find that same zone.
And so, look for that
thing, find that thing,
and for me this community is that thing
and I want to thank you
from the bottom of my heart.
Thank you so much, have the
best, best rest of the weekend,
have the best summer, flip, start things,
produce content, but most of all listen.
The audacity that everybody
wants likes, and comments,
and subscribers but
doesn't want to then do
for them what they want in return.
The selfishness of give me
vanity, metrics, and social,
and content, and digital, yet the key is
if you listened and cared
about those individuals
as much as what you wanted from them
in likes and subscribers,
everything would be different.
Please do not take things for granted
and most of all do not take
your community for granted
'cause it is the foundation
of your opportunity
in this digital world, see ya.